Army Recruitment ads China versus Russia
versus USA right so they're showing up
this looks like China at first if I had
to take a wild guess it's true
excuse me
that language really is dope though
sounds so cool
[Music]
couldn't have had translations on it
look at this it's about discipline
accomplishment power you can feel it I
want to join the Chinese Army watching
this
I'm all set but I hear you
to be
America
now we have trans Army ads wait I can't
even wait to see the American money
myself
this is sick
it is cool to see like a Chinese
military ad I've never seen one yeah
did you watch this and you're like I'm
not [ __ ] with China
you
it does sound like an anime bro am I
wrong
[Music]
have you seen a woman in there in their
army
notice
they're not worried about being woke
that is dope
this is Russian
I would have loved if they had
translations wait do they
oh really good when you will know it
oh
yeah
and fight bear in the morning and then I
wake up with six raw eggs
brother
Ashley
yeah
kick ass
no
oh my God what is this [ __ ] why are
there already there's the more girls on
the screen than
three dudes and two guys
for the ad oh no please no this is
horrible this is the story of a soldier
who operates who are nation's Patriot
missile defense systems
it begins in California
with a little girl raised by two moms oh
my God this can't be real this can't be
real oh my God we are doomed this
country is dude this is a fad this is
going to pass is this real I don't know
let's just watch it some of the army ads
we get are cool so I'll give I'll give
us that some of them are some of them
are dope this nah bro
this is this is messed up notice how in
the other ads all you all you saw was
strong men they didn't even show a woman
in there because if you really want the
strongest military you're not having
women running around with guns doing all
that [ __ ] it doesn't make sense it's not
their place in the world and that's not
a bad thing it's not a bad thing at all
women should be protected well no I
don't have any problem with women in the
military if they can do the job hey have
at it I know I please I'm gonna just
just keep just keep it real if I had to
fight against 100 guys or 100 women that
excuse me because I know it's how guys
here and it's the horrible thing nobody
wants to talk about but like it's gross
but like if you had that time in a month
and you got to be like in a jungle
somewhere like in a you know up to your
waist crawling through water to find the
enemy and you got that going on trust me
like that's a nightmare and that would
be a nightmare and some women are are
tough enough to mentally handle that and
they can do it fine let them have at it
but to make it seem like this is that
that that is going to be the real true
strength and backbone is [ __ ] it is
a true [ __ ] it is the truth it is
the strong the strength growing up with
two moms
that's a mom there's nothing wrong with
any of this in an ad for I don't know
Art School
although I had a fairly typical
childhood took ballet
played violin
I also marched for equality
I like to think I've been defending
freedom from an early age
yeah that's what those protests look
like six years old yeah one of my moms
had an accident that left her paralyzed
doctors said she might never walk again
she tapped into my family's Pride to get
back on her feet
eventually standing at the altar to
marry my other mom
with such powerful role models
I finished high school at the top of my
class
and then attended UC Davis where I
joined a sorority full of other strong
women there's no way this is real but
it's great sorority of other strong
women yeah okay that's that's yeah
sororities are all nice strong women
what does this have to do with um
with the military let's go I want to
know what this has to do with you know
just getting drunk this girl this story
doesn't make me want to sleep better at
night stereotype
sure I'd spent my life around inspiring
women
but what had I really achieved on my own
one of my sorority sisters was studying
abroad in Italy another was climbing
Mount Everest
I needed my own another one was sleeping
around with the basketball team
and after meeting with an army recruiter
and maybe shatter some stereotypes along
the way
I'm U.S army Corporal Emma Malone Lord
and I answered my calling all right you
know what okay if that wasn't bro what
okay let's go that is it ladies and
gentlemen stop this that was not a fair
comparison of ads because we do have
some badass act we do have cool ads
especially after Top Gun movie came out
this year the Air Force came out with
some kick-ass ads they were like oh I'm
sure Air Force they they came out and it
was just all guns of Blaze and flying
cool stuff so we do have some just
listen excuse me I'm setting up the next
thing you know we weren't comparing the
badass adds to the badass ads that ad as
much as it doesn't Inspire confidence
you know listen it doesn't make me feel
any safer when I sleep at night I have
to say if that gets these these dumb
woke sorority girls to wake up and say
maybe there's something more important I
can do with my life then complain so be
it and to that girl who was in the end
of the ad who is has is serving you know
what I thank her for her service and I'm
grateful for her service because she is
playing a part that matters so you know
what
I'm gonna bother getting mad about that
[Music]
[Music]